We collect COVID-19 related tweets ranging from February 1, 2020 to September 30, 2021.
For data preprocessing, we first remove non-English tweets and retweets.
Then we filter out the tweets containing URL.
Afterwards, we use a list of symptoms as keywords to match the tweets to extract medical related tweets.
Finally, 10,000 tweets are annotated.
Among them, 6,000 are randomly sampled, and the other 4,000 are from the model label data.
All of them are manually checked.
We define seven entity types based on public health research needs.
including three general entity tabs and four medical entity tabs for annotation.
In particular, we select four entity tabs for additional sentiment annotation with three types of sentiment labels, positive, negative,